asking you the right question was it  broke if you're telling me right now  it's broken that's real it's your words  you said the system is broken right now  so therefore if the toy was broken today  does that mean the toy was was not  broken yesterday  um well because because what I'm  thinking is there's like multiple points  that I would pinpoint that started to  like cause the decline of relationships  in the west so it's like you could say  no fault divorce but like then I would I  would also argue that birth control  contributed I would argue like at the  beginning of feminists I don't believe  in like first wave second wave Third Way  like I think there's multiple things